They have brought Charlie Kirk back from
the dead. And he's got a message.
>> Don't worry about me. I'm in a better
place now. But America and Israel from
this day on will never be the same.
>> Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have,
case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, umrah, salah, fasting, what? No
sodaka brothers and sisters is getting
thousands of shahadas monthly yearly.
Hundreds of thousands of people are
coming to Islam. They are printing
Quran, distributing material, training
duat. Brothers and sisters, do you want
the part of that goes on forever. This
is how Islam has spread around the
world. Brothers and sisters, carry on
this legacy of the prophetam inshallah
by donating whatever amount inshallah
and support right now inshallah. Enjoy
the video
to brothers and sisters and difference.
I genuinely thought I was speaking to
some brothers before when Charlie got
hit and got killed. I was thinking you
know what I won't be surprised if these
guys you know do like an you know like
an interview with him from the dead and
tried to and I was like yo you know like
seriously they might you know be like
you know he's vouching you know he's
dead now but you know they might use AI
was just laughing about it and uh lo and
behold uh that's exactly what they've
done here they've brought him back from
the dead. They have brought Charlie Kirk
back from the dead. And he's got a
message. Is this message that guys, I
changed my mind about Apac, about
Israel. I I'm frightened for my life. My
Jewish Israeli donors are putting
pressure on me. Be Benjamin the Satan
has offered me $150 million. I've
rejected that. He's called me to Israel.
I've rejected that. He's read a part of
my letter, which it took it out of
context completely. Just one part of it.
But let's see, guys. Let's see what they
when they went back from the dead with
AI. Let's see what is it that Charlie
Kirk has to say. You can't these people
are evil on another level. Like evil.
Let's here's Charlie Kirk's message to
the Americans and to the whole wide
world. Um from the dead. Here we go.
>> This is evil. Israel using AI to put
words in a dead man's mouth for their
own propaganda.
>> Don't worry about me. I'm in a better
place now. But America and Israel from
this day on will never be the same.
This is the wakeup call moment. They
tried to shut me up. They couldn't stand
a voice that didn't sound like theirs.
And that's exactly why we have to fight.
We exposed the lie. I spoke the truth
and they hated every second of it. I
know you guys are hurting.
Feels like you lost me. You didn't. You
can't kill an idea. You can't murder
faith.
Spirit doesn't break. They mocked me. I
kept going. Tried to silence me. I spoke
louder. They warned me. No way. Truth's
worth the price every single time.
Miracles built on faith, on freedom, on
family. Same with Israel. Standing tall,
fighting back, never backing down.
That's our bond. That's our story.
Here's the thing. Those who tried to
scare me only made me stronger. Those
who tried to silence me proved I was
right. So I'm asking you, don't go
quiet. Don't bend. Don't give in.
America needs you. Israel needs you.
When people remember me, let it be for
courage, for faith, for hope. Because
this wasn't the end. This was the
opening shot of a change that's coming.
And it's going to be for the better.
That is an evil thing to do, especially
since Charlie Kirk stopped taking money
from Israel and was even turning against
them the last few months that he was
alive. So, that makes that extra evil Zo
propaganda right there.
>> So, guys,
let's just read some of the comments
here. Okay. Um, I hope you guys enjoyed
the video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app, brothers and
sisters. We are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kiblinder, no ads, free salah reminders,
encourages to pray, tells you salah
times. You can book a salah instructor,
a Quran instructor. You can order a
guided prayer map for absolutely free if
you want to learn how to pray salah.
Videos on how to pray salah. Salah hubs
and many many more brother sisters. We
are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy
guys. Let's go back to the video.
Disgusting and shameful. They are
getting so desperate right now. Israel
propaganda video trying to get the US to
fight each other. Wow. Israel really
laughing in our face right now. Of
course. Didn't he just say Israel was
ethnically cleansing Palestine? Yep. I
just project our vomiting everywhere.
Okay. So guys um in this is an evil on
of all evilness. These guys are the
kings of evilness. So you can see
bringing a look at the propaganda. They
don't even leave the dead alone. They
don't even leave the dead alone. The
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him told
us don't speak bad or good of these and
you know their affairs with Allah.
Chapter close. Just leave it at that. We
are not allowed to speak ill, you know,
in that sense were insulting, etc. We
know what Charlie Kirk was about sadly
and we can see that he was changing his
mind. You can see that he knew he was
brainwashed and you've seen many other
videos of candy etc exposing that he was
going against Israel and you can see
that in my other video. But it makes you
a special kind of sicko to go and get an
AI generated uh visuals of an in an
individual who has been shot, killed,
assassinated for your propaganda. You
did not respect him when he was turned
against you in this life. He was
bullying him. You was bullying him. Nor
do you leave him alone when he's dead.
When the man is alive, you're on his
case. When he is dead, you don't let the
guy be dead. No. And this is how evil
they are. These people are the pinnacle
of evilness. And alhamdulillah, God
Almighty is opening the reality, showing
people the reality, the truth that Islam
is the truth. Because when people look
at the cause of the Palestinians and see
our resistance, the resistance that they
have, that's when mothers who have seen
the limbs of their children are saying,
"Alhamdulillah, people are flocking to
Islam in our Dow tables, flocking." One
of the main reasons is what?
Palestinians. Cuz they're like, "How are
these people so strong? It's Allah.
Nothing to do with the Palestinians or
us. It's Allah, the one true creator who
created the heavens and the earth, who
created Jesus, Moses, Abraham, Adam,
prophet, peace be upon all of them. It's
the one true religion. And that is the
reason why you see all of these nations
against one place and that is the
Muslims. A group of people, subhan
Allah, that are asking for people to
worship God alone. And alhamdulillah,
don't forget, and I said this before,
Charlie Kirk, the way he would belittle
the Palestinians, what they go for, his
that's his legacy until he was changing
his mind, but they took him out before
he can speak further. Brothers and
sisters, this is the sick nation of
Israel, the sick nation of Israel that
are condoning, killing, masculine people
and now are using a dead man for their
propaganda. You cannot make this up.
United States of Israel,
wake up. Wake up to this reality. And
they are waking up.